Five years ago, when I was
elected President, I said that my goal is to make
the European Parliament more visible,
audible and more influential.
Five years later, I can say that
we have succeeded together. The
Parliament is visible today, more
audible and more influential than
ever  before
here in this room the important debates take
place here
decisions are made that make people's lives
better and safer
but precisely this transnational
democracy is in great danger today
everywhere on this continent
the splitters and the ultra-nationalists are
spreading again
those people against each other
rushing and who, like the liberals, want to do away with the
social and ecological
society model, they
are endangering one of the greatest
achievements of civilization that has
existed on our continent. with
all my
might, i will continue to stand up against this hatred in the future,
no matter what  cher point out i was
certainly not a comfortable and also not an
easy president of this house
but i have tried to the best of my
knowledge and belief to fight for the cause of europe
so that people
and peoples can overcome rifts
yesterday's award of the
sakharov prize has us emphatically
exactly  reminds it's up to us
ladies and gentlemen
to hand over to our children and renke europe as a place that
stands for this hope full of
humility
thank you for working together
over these five years
thank you very much
[music]